in keiner anderen karten in uns
betroffen
heute möchte ich euch ein ganz schnelles
rezept zeigen und zwar habe ich eine
hochzeitstorte gemacht und diese nicht
mit von dort überzogen sondern mit
modelliert schokolade dekoriert und
heute möchte ich euch in diesem kleinen
video einfach mal zeigen wie moderne
schokolade ganz einfach selber
herzustellen geht und dass ihr braucht
ihr nur zwei zutaten man kann module
schokolade auch fertig kaufen
da gibt's auch mehrere anbieter und
hersteller ich hab nämlich so den
perfekten richtigen gefunden und zeigt
euch deswegen einfach mal wie's geht und
zwar benutzen wir dafür 250 gramm
kuvertüre das ist jetzt weiße kuvertüre
und ihr könnt die sache auch mit dunkle
kuvertüre also mit vollmilch oder
zartbitter machen aber da ändert sich
einfach das verhältnis zwischen
schokolade und den glukose sirup den wir
auch brauchen
hier habe ich jetzt 90 gramm und zwar
braucht ihr bei dunkler schokolade und
dunkle kuvertüre einfach etwas mehr von
dem glukose sirup
ich nehme jetzt einfach kuvertüre und
keine normale schokolade bei dieser
einfachen erwartet
es gebe jetzt mein abgekochtes wasser
gehen meine schlüsse ziehen rein
wir möchten nämlich dass die kuvertüre
geschmolzen wird und auch dass die das
denken kurse sirup einfach die selben
tempo
deswegen stelle ich jetzt hier in die
eine schüssel den glukose sirup und in
die andere schüsseln seine kuvertüre die
habe ich einfach schon fein gehackt und
die kuvertüre verrührt so lange bis sie
komplett geschmolzen ist und in der zeit
erhitzt sich darauf kam der kotierung
libyschen volk aus ich nehme mit
kuvertüre wahl bei kuvertüre der
fettgehalt immer gleich ist also wenn
ich zum beispiel weiße schokolade nimmt
ist da ein anderer fettgehalt drin wie
beide dunkler schokolade
aber wenn wir profitieren nehmen dann
ist der fettgehalt immer bei ungefähr 36
gramm pro 100 km und da führt einfach
sicher sein dass es verhältnisse
bestimmt
jetzt ist die schokolade geschmolzen und
ihr könnt es natürlich auch in der
mikrowelle machen aber ich bevorzuge die
methode hierüber am wasserrad weil das
sicher geht das nicht verbrennt
jetzt kann ich den ökosystemen jetzt
auch schön erwärmt ist und dieser muss
warnt seien damit dass ich jetzt mit der
schokolade verbindet den gebe ich jetzt
hier mit dazu
doch jede letzte schöne auskratzen mit
seinem körperbild das runterfahren
und jetzt einfach ganz langsam denn die
große chance mit der schokolade von
hinten
ohne dabei zu viel zu hören wenn wir
jetzt zu sehr wird das fett aus der
schokolade freigesetzt und dann kommt
eben sein das ist sehr über das ganze
feld raus tor
deswegen letzteres recht
und diesen glukose sirup da musst du
einfach darauf achten dass es einer ist
da eben schön dickflüssig ist und ich
weiß mittlerweile nicht wieder vom
grafschafter ist dann bekommt man ja im
supermarkt dann habe ich früher auch
gerne verwendet um ein von land
herzustellen
aber danach mittlerweile irgendwie etwas
flüssiger geworden und dieser hier ist
schön dick den kölner zum beispiel auch
beim impfstoff bestellen und ihr seht
auch die schokolade mit dann gar nicht
schön fest dass ihr dürft da nicht diese
bar xerox verwenden die plötzlich aus
der flasche sind sondern es muss richtig
schöner dicker fast die ganze große
sirup sein
der fester ist als honig und ihr seht es
jetzt wenn ich den sparte hoch nehme
wieder schokolade dann löst die sich
verboten
und es ist genau der zeitpunkt wird
einfach aufhört zu rühren hatte grad so
dass sich alles verbunden hat und dann
nicht weiteren einfach so lassen
jetzt brauche ich etwas recherche folie
breit ich hier einfach raus und gibt es
jetzt steht auch dass ich noch relativ
reich aber das wird jetzt beim abkühlen
und wester wir wissen ja schokolade ist
ja im geschmolzenen zugestanden flüssig
und wird dann drückt es ein bisschen
flach damit schneller abkühlt denn wenn
es so ein großer brocken bleibt dann
dauert es natürlich viel länger und wenn
ihr etwas flach drückt dann geht es
natürlich viel schneller
so mache ich das immer wenn ihr fleisch
einführen er friere ich keinen wollen
macht es noch platz und so las ich das
jetzt bei zimmertemperatur für
mindestens zehn bis zwölf stunden
bestehen damit die schokolade wieder
fest wird ihr könnt es natürlich auch
beschleunigen indem ihr das in den
kühlschrank rät aber ich finde es besser
wenn man aus einer zimmertemperatur
brachte und dann werde ich euch morgen
erwacht das endergebnis zeigen
ich habe meine modelle schokolade über
nacht einfach weiß thema temperatur
stehen lassen und zeigt euch jetzt mal
das ergebnis zwar merkt man dass sie
ziemlich fest geworden ist und ich warte
jetzt einfach etwas zusammen
und dann wird sie auch schön geschmeidig
und je länger man knetet umso
geschmeidiger wird sie dann auch
und am besten lass dir sie jetzt nach
dem kneten nochmal und benutzt sie dann
erst am nächsten und das gleiche habe
ich hier auch mit dunkler schokolade
gemacht als mit kuvertüre und da ist das
gleiche prinzip dabei ist jetzt auch
durchkneten und nochmal in folie
einwickeln und eingewickelt in folie
hält diese modelle gerade sogar mehrere
monate einfach bei zimmertemperatur ihr
könnt sie gerne auch in den kühlschrank
geben aber nimmt sie einfach vor der
verwendung heraus damit sie wieder
zimmertemperatur annimmt und das kneten
nicht so schwer wird und aus dieser
schokolade lassen sich dann zum beispiel
schokoladen rosen herstellen also das
könnt ihr einfach verarbeiten wie
marzipan oder von ihr könnt daraus die
dekoration machen für die hochzeitstorte
so wie ich sie gemacht habe oder ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch komplett eine
torte damit überziehen
das ist natürlich etwas aufwendiger und
schwieriger und ja das war so das rezept
zur schokolade und jetzt möchte ich euch
noch ein paar neuheiten vorstellen
und zwar haben wir seit heute achte
freie fahrten im shop und zwar sind die
pastellfarben aus der trübe und ich bin
echt stolz darauf dass ihr euch
eigentlich so präsentieren dürfen oder
ich besser gesagt weil wir
deutschlandweit der erste online-shop
mit assad reinpassen farben die auf gute
qualität haben
es gibt ja schon im supermarkt passen
oder farbe neben lebensmittelfarben ohne
azofarbstoffe das waren bisher einfach
diese farben und das flüssige farben
arbeiten waren bisher nicht sehr gut man
kann auch keinen von dorda mit pferden
und mit diesen passen fahrten kann man
nicht alles werden
also man kann damit von dort
kann den teig werden man kann zuckerguss
damit werden also wirklich alles und
diese gibt es ab sofort im shop darüber
mache ich nächste woche ein video gleich
dazu
sie sind in der handhabung genauso wie
die anderen farben
man braucht einfach nur etwas mehr fahre
aber das erkläre ich euch alles in
meinem nächsten video nächste woche und
wir haben auch ein kilo fronter endlich
im eimer bis den ich noch nicht super
toll weil man kann so den vom dorf
benutzen und dann einfach wieder einfach
und da kann man das drama und ich finde
einmal echt super wiederverwertbar und
diese produkte kommen alle von der firma
de cuba sie kommen gerade bei uns um die
ecke 20 minuten von hier aus ginsheim
und es sind 13 jungs die einfach super
ideen haben und da kann ich auch immer
hingehen und sagen hey ich hätte gern
dieses oder dieses produkt und dann
arbeiten wir da jetzt zusammen dran und
ich finde es echt super vor allen dingen
mit den apfel freien farben weil wir uns
diese ist schon so lange gewünscht haben
und endlich ist es da malt und ja sogar
der sondern ist astrein und die farben
sind einfach super als es sicher
schwierig ein angstfreies wo zum
beispiel herzustellen und dass ich
einfach glücklich und diese gibt es wie
gesagt bei mir ab sofort im online-shop
oder auch demnächst in supermärkten wie
zum beispiel bloß rewe edeka und noch
weitere die ich euch einfach unten in
der infobox reinschreiben werde ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß mit
dem rezept der module schokolade und
hoffe dass euch gefällt dass wir endlich
die ernte einfahren
im shop haben ich wünsche euch
eigentlich einen ganz schönen tag und
die hochzeitstorte müsste auf jeden fall
auch anschauen
die habe ich nämlich mit dieser modelle
schokolade gemacht